[Music]
he ever heard about 14 year olds I was
the weird segment that made no sense I
really like these Billy a leash means
but it's the exact same punchline in the
exact same setup it's like I wish there
were something more but this is it Billy
Eilish coughs in microphone
fourteen-year-old girls all I have our
negative thoughts he took us on the
counter fourteen-year-old girls
he hit H er oh my god this is so
incredible sad this meme come from Billy
Elish that he hit her I think I saw ya
Billy Elish she's broken he's okay he's
okay
that's amazing not he's okay
so bad it's an old tired joke but I'm
going with it anyway nobody 14 year old
girls listening to Billy Eilish oh my
god how deep is like I someone actually
dug out a very old video line just for
that Thank You Billy Elish I was born on
my birthday whoa that's so deep crying
cats make me laugh don't judge me okay
all right rating time zero pee pee poo
poos I'm sorry got nothing on me not
that interested I wish I was however
next me next mean hello all right let's
do an older meme just because I I
purposely didn't have this one in last
name review okay I know the memes I'm
down with the kids it's just the
spongebob stuff can get claimed okay it
has happened before I'm looking at you
Sony TV publishing you snake
you absolutely suck it succulent
disgusting your lard you're a fat lard
that no one wants to suck on I don't
want to suck on you Wi-Fi drops down by
one bar YouTube video quality I am about
to head out when you already headed out
I already had it out
Jesus on third date hi I'm ahead out
he did he did head out that's the joke
when you're the first letter of the
alphabet ma hey I like that one that
actually made me laugh congratulation me
my girl me my girl my playstation my
girl I I want some attention my god
it's so true lungs breathing breathing
oxygen carbon dioxide I'm about to head
out my god what a clever joke that's
great
when you finish remaking a meme in HD
but you realize it's already dead
I have a head up that actually looks
very pleasing well then I stand up too
fast my vision I am a head out this
confused me so much when I was a kid
okay no one talked about it I'm like
what are these flying things I'm like no
you're crazy I'm like I swear I say that
what are they
I'm sorry seriously I was like wait what
is happening why am I the only one
talking about this I don't know how to
describe it either I'm like there's like
dots blinking and I don't know what they
are
now damnit school teach you nothing I'm
sure there's like a 20 minute YouTube
video over someone talking about it who
actually Blu Blu Blu fix it I don't even
care just tell me what it is I don't
need to I don't want to watch the 20
minute video I just want to know you
know I'll go get it I'll google it
science section of meme review happening
right now I'm googling it what are the
lights that shine when I stand up too
quick orthostatic hypotension alright
cool I don't care
can you just explain what it is it's
blood rushing to your head alright
I feel like I can't find the answer so
there must be a conspiracy alien reptile
lights I knew it when you sell the same
games each year with overpriced DLC I'm
EA you mean every big gaming publishing
company alright
I uh hey go out that's awful this mean
he gets a blip that's all I get
I don't know what do you want it solely
deserves and that solely gets and it is
only it will ever be
it's another Sponge Bob mean and the
pool of spongebob means I do like it
though cuz whenever I go now I can say I
I'm about to head out and much that can
be like okay and I can be like I just
did a meme thanks babe
disappointed green face man I forgot
what his name is called the guy from
Monsters Inc where his name Michael
there you go you can delete your comment
now this is how little kids stare at you
in in public areas for no reason why do
kids do this why do they stare at you
stop you know when I was a kid not I was
like young teenager a kid stared at me
at the bus and I was so annoyed by it
and we are so I stared back with that
face I was like but what I didn't know
was that his parents were sitting next
to the kid and I looked over her and
he's looking at me with the same face
but he goes what the are you doing and
we were on a bus I couldn't go anywhere
I was really awkward Bell delphi's
parents when they found out what she did
for a living okay teacher anyone who
doesn't want to be in class can get out
everyone in class leaves teacher you
just got trolled teacher ethically okay
don't ask questions you don't want
answers to teacher got your nose that's
a good mean now that's a really good one
I like that one a lot I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but that's a spicy
spicy meatball okay very good meme
fantastic why does he have the nose has
he always had the nose oh my god Mike
doesn't have the nose Mike doesn't have
the nose oh it's ass face one oh now I
get why it's funny like behind on
everything introduces my girlfriend to
my family my wife and three kids what
I'm not supposed to
it's time to go was that a good meme no
I realized this meme format is one that
I never really reviewed there's so many
good memes from that fakes explosion in
general total region so he doesn't feel
bad doctor during my prostate exam I
just envisioned it and it was not a
prize inside moving ahead that was it
that's it for Mike Jerry Seinfeld guy
that big this one gets it's just that
sound nothing else how random and quirky
next mean this has happened to everyone
you forget something and the other
person says oh if you forgot it it's
probably not important which this is in
line it's a line they're just saying
that to move on with the conversation
because they're sick of waiting for you
to go mmm
at least that's how I do it we don't
think I know why you're not why you're
saying it someone made that into me pity
pie I think I forgot something
nine-year-olds if you're dot then it
wasn't important probably yeah you're
right I forgot my son I mean 100 million
bro please you got it brofist you got it
and it was epic reddit I think I forgot
something also ready if you forgot then
it wasn't important reddit you are right
Amazon rainforest still burning everyone
forgot about that literally any sort of
social movement costs give it a week or
two what you don't drink paper straws
the teacher I think I forgot something
the class if you forgot that it wasn't
important the teacher yeah you're right
the homework this is so sad F's in the
chat for homework everyone melons in the
chat for the homework I think I forgot
something tap here to add tags okay
that's clever I like it physics teachers
solid liquid gas physics teachers plasma
it's plasma another element why didn't
no one teach me that probably wasn't
important this mean gets an nope we lose
sorry gamers better luck next time I'm
not supposed to give opinion I really
like this next mean it's limited in
stock but we'll see a jump back when
ever someone does something else you
know how I'm walking dead they have that
stupid door and you're reading you're
like don't dead open inside
okay well that's stupid why would you
write it like that and it's a pretty
dumb sign because clearly there are
already we can tell also they spelled
cafeteria wrong they wrote cafeteria
that does not exist can we talk about
that there's no such thing as cafeteria
it's called cafeteria you dumb dumps
dead inside more like brain dead inside
MRI gamers small brain inside that's
right
but there's a couple other great
examples of this especially in shops
like back foot open rub-rub seven days
rub rub seven days
sign me up gamers this one is really
brilliant though cuz even if you read it
either way it works
shades design shades this side damn it
you win this round shades design but
I'll get you next time
stupid shades design ruin my life a sign
that is difficult to read slap this meme
template on it I have achieved comedy
but it's funny come on stop let me have
fun please you don't matter give the
best styles best touch dammit you win
this round best styles but I'll get you
next time yeah that's right I'm not
afraid to hit you best side I know at
least one person named Bret Stiles is
watching this and you're I don't like
you
you don't matter worry boy it's funny
come on come on please please it's funny
go I have to keep convincing and fix my
camera hello hello what's the
temperature it's not 25 in here it's way
too high after these stupid lights on me
sorry we don't over 20 bills except
that's English why did he write except
on the right side why would you do that
oh I get it sorry we don't accept bills
owing spirals
so dog well why would you write the
sentence as a spiral my god
Jesus Christ ooh men's day oh my laughs
came out a little too strong but man
that's good
vent Oh clever math version of meme oh
no all right this meme gets that's right
big big day big day for everyone I
thought there was one more oh damn
that's another clever one stop look
life's but not least we have the crying
guy and the guy putting on sunglasses
that's what the meme is called that's
you google that and you'll find this
meme they it has no other names
seven-year-old me when the teacher seats
me next to a girl 14-year old me when
the teacher seats me next to a girl
epic having hundred dollars as an adult
having twenty dollars as a kid get
diagnosed with an unknown disease you
get to name it that's all is that the
doctor comes in I got bad news you'll
never walk again I realize the joke is
funnier if I just don't say anything
else
receiving a nude from here classmate
you're in an old boys school you're all
gay epic when your gift shopping and end
up finding some stuff that's that looks
better in your closet oh it's another
one send memes end me me after sending a
drunk text and knowing damn well I've
been wanting to say that is that how it
originated be telling everyone that I
want to die me the day I nearly choked
in a piss thing I finally asked my crush
out she says yes she keeps hurting me
right away I wake up you see okay that
was a trip realizing you can make a meme
on Emma's paint it won't have good
quality pixel art is still good so you
do it anyways amazing boys playing
Minecraft
girls playing Minecraft were we
your crush finding out you like her to
you finding out your crush likes you too
and other hilarious jokes you can tell
yourself and other things that never
will never happen this mean it was the
last meme and it gets as well to in
their row that's awesome
alright gamers hope you guys enjoyed
this episode if you did go ahead and
smash like I know I haven't warned the
hundred million club merch and I've been
throwing it down your throats
I lost my versions someone must have
stolen them I don't know where they are
that's literally how attractive they are
check it out represent do it now before
it's too late
Oh God and see you tomorrow
subscribe what you haven't tried to
persuade me later today after 50 million
outros fetch go just go it's still
relevant just down a bit